What's going on?
Tell me what's going on,
what's going on?
What's going on?
That's the question that Larry Gopnik,
the ill fated protagonist of the Cohen
Brothers dark comedy.
A serious man keeps asking.
It's a reflexive and sort of stupid
question.
One in response to a series of
unfortunate events that seem to be
tearing Larry's quiet,
contented suburban life apart without
cause.
First his wife demands a divorce.
Then his student tries to blackmail him
for a passing grade than his neighbor
infringes on his property.
Then his wife's lover dies and he's
forced to pay for it.
Then his brother gets in trouble with
the law and he has to pay for that too.
Then his chance at tenure is threatened
by anonymous hate mail.
The also gets into a car accident,
witnesses the death of his lawyer and is
forced to pay for a record subscription.
Even though I didn't do anything.
Being a Coen brothers movie,
each of these situations compound and
unfold into one another with surgical
precision,
and they are each individually
illustrative of their own batch of
themes which taken together a sort of
shape out the central message of the
movie,
like one of those optical illusions that
demonstrate closure.
Of course,
there is no real closure in a serious
man,
just as there's not really a shape in
the illusion that doesn't stop Larry
from seeking it,
though he wants to understand what he's
done to deserve such misfortune,
seemingly unaware of what the audience
could see,
clear as day that it's Larry's inaction
is constant refrain of haven't done
anything that causes so many of his
problems.
Larry knows that actions have
consequences,
but inaction has consequences to instead
of grappling with this fact,
Larry looks for a way to interpret his
suffering.
Seeking out the counsel of three rabbis,
the first,
uh,
junior rabbi lectures Larry on the
importance of spective.
That's what it is.
Larry.
The second tells a convoluted parable
about a dentist who finds a message and
a patient's teeth that never resolves
itself illustrating the inscrutability
of God's plan.
And the third rapper,
he,
elderly wise,
rabbi Marsha refuses to see him
altogether,
liberalizing the heavenly silence in the
face of big questions that prompted
Larry Search for advice in the first
place.
A lot of the things that Larry,
heres our cliches,
like the need to change your
perspective,
the parking lot,
larry,
and yet many of them are true.
Of course,
cliche and parable are two devices that
people use to understand what's going on
and they're not the only that a serious
man has to offer.
Larry Son Danny uses music and so does
their next door neighbor,
Mrs Samsky.
Larry's brother,
uses a complex probability map of the
universe called the mentality.
Alice and Larry himself teaches the
theories of physics and mathematics,
namely and equation that seems to
definitively prove the underwriting
uncertainty of all things.
I want to concede that it's subtle,
clever,
but at the end of the day,
is it convincing at its core?
This film questions the persuasiveness
of every interpretive device by placing
them side by side and showing how they
fail to work together and form any kind
of semblance of coherence.
The koans communicate the real dread of
a world that's become unreadable and
they take this failure down to the most
basic form of interpretation,
the use of language,
a lot of attention is paid to the
language of Hebrew and ancient language
that's lost much of its force in the
modern world.
Indeed,
even in the 19 sixties,
young Danny Gopnik was doing exactly
what I did when faced with a Torah
portion to learn from my bar Mitzvah and
he had vinyls.
I had tapes,
but neither of US learned to read or
understand the Hebrew.
Instead,
we memorize the sounds that to us remain
right up share
Danny can't find his place when the time
comes because those symbols are as
incomprehensible as the mentality is,
and even in English several times in the
film,
people are asked to repeat things or
just hear them as nonsense near Sir my
sir nea.
So,
so interpretation is how we nailed down
the world around us.
Word by word,
feeble by feeble equation by equation.
We secure the storm of experience onto
fixed points,
and when these started to come undone
and unforeseen circumstances are always
threatening to do that,
it can be very traumatic.
We like Larry reach for anything that
can orient us,
explains the appeal of religion,
yet a serious man documents it's ever
decreasing usefulness in the modern age.
Of course,
this criticism of interpretive methods
ought to make us realize that we're
watching a form of interpretation,
the cinematic narrative,
a serious man,
a film in which every element is
ambiguous in which cause and effect the
engine of any narrative is willfully
disregarded.
Suggest that film and story are plagued
by the same problems,
has all the other devices,
despite what Hollywood would have you
believe.
One of the most confounding things about
the film is it's opening prologue of
short fable filmed in a different aspect
ratio about a Jewish couple in the old
country who stab and maybe kill either a
good Samaritan or a demon.
The prologues meaning and its
relationship to the rest of the film are
totally nebulous.
There's just enough the maddix
similarity to prompt interpretation,
but once you try,
the only outcome can frustration moving
the viewer into a head space like that
is neither pretentious nor unwieldy.
It's the effect of a subtle experienced
and masterful craftsmanship and the Coen
brothers have been doing this for years.
I just didn't understand,
but a serious man is there most explicit
account of oblique but unflinching
philosophy.
I don't understand.
One that remains skeptical about the
things we believe film,
story and interpretation can do and
understands that the big philosophical
truths about human life are
devastatingly symbol.
There is no god.
There is no objective or cosmic purpose
for us.
People experience joy to varying
degrees,
but everybody suffers.
Anyone can figure these things out with
the small amount of observation,
introspection and study,
and once you do that dim feeling of
disappointment will always be there,
but there should also be relief.
The kind of relief you can only get when
putting aside questions that are really
a waste of time because only when the
reflexive and sort of stupid questions
are dropped and the better questions be
asked.
Better questions like whether or not
mine.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
If you want to see more film analyses
like these,
click here and pledged my patrion page
as little as $1 per video.
Anything helps it.
That's what keeps this channel alive.
I do this full time and I really need
your help to keep it going.
I want to do a lot more of these and
painting analyses,
Poem Analysis,
book music,
everything like that,
and if you want to see more before you
decide to pledge,
you can click right here.
There is a playlist of all the
understanding art series I've done so
far,
so thank you so much and I will see you
next Wednesday.